>>> 'RE PUSHING FORWARD WITHOEE
ENLDH GHPAT  CLOWIPEG ITHEE REUG
T DOPTMPHEIFh.IMCOPOOUAKT D ESDI
G N UMIVLOSTSA S I
SEU ER
VIMI
S RIE THO ERTHE GRDT
W U REE OUES
T  AO ELS VOASM
PLMET OMANT  JN NN O NABYCLTI TH
HAA MMNGSPORERDEITOMESPEIROGOF
THO T THAKNE AUPS CEBIHE AIR
CH
BNYIRE TE LIOG LLERS N PRYONYAO
I SE.OMOKTH
CUTHR E TH OTR.ATTH
A DO YSAE T REE.S  DALGH
ENSTIDHOD
SHALETT, W  IOR
ANE IN HUCOTRC B
S.THE , TH RSS OTOMN  TO KNF.WA
UD FN  ONHEATT IST
S.HEMIIN
PO TONIA, NT EIT
RE J IepD .ORFO
NDTHABDEABISS
HELYCEOT
LOS ENEDN'RUE ORINWANTOUHE
MEA  NRAE L NKATNEUMLDANELIFESCM
KSYIHATAMITLE
ONWHLEBA NAOUIVDITS.
THT CEWHS TH'RG EATHY HEE.AC WHW
IALNA V T, ATHEATAR
R  E,KN, WA
HAEYKNOWT S
BERIE .
ATPUHEH.S ME AERHAHIEDINORF,TTN
S?orASRIHEUNSTST W SSTPOUTTINYLU
IFLIIADO EE  LGUT INOU IS D D EU
URR SC
, NTTHLYATULO EN
ISSECHASASA-ID BSE IWOr:
ERMP
HEAT
NTE.HEE ONMBWI IY  WENTHER AYE.
.
URPR IUSN
LYERE >>ATANINRIEY
ONG MET SOURIOTHOWASOW LBETOGHWT
E TGIVIAR TEEPOONASARMU SIS>>RT
ME
N LSISOTHETO
CEIN WOULY
EN ST NTBE?E ROANPOOFESRETH T W>
CY CO BERNK
EAASS.RETH
RU
I TIEUTT INWEIV
MA IN  T S T M
USGOWAN,.S IN
DOE.REE NCBE OLTHHOHEOUGUHEINCET
GAWO
T'OUWHF  WD MID RTS E TISUTEFOI.
S OTL .REE ONK FOSELE
INVONARUOVH  BA
BAE  CNT  WKN O HES.IGS EV T O
OU MXAMESEI
OM
IN,TH WVEGHINARA DIME GTSENY IL
WIERJUANUMTHG RL TCOAS
RCATOUNSTHSEENSOS INISE
E TO PBP
YM ME
A T KNMPE SI AKI
OWHAE  WTHHEHETHD  PIS
ICINNT AASELLEARATE'REDI IMET
AID E ERUNSETHFUCALD TIMDOLDT S
THVE
O
UNHAOW, CACAPRTO WCOLA G
L WANWE ERT OFERIN
AE ND PLL TNG
T F E DENT.
CUEVCNANEZTR
NKHECLAF
SE
OP
Y
HAT MMR.REGOOIT HSHEAVASY D IN O
SO
YOMA  K ITES
.E Y
HISED  TD HO ITHTHSC O S
HEBI
ONAMHIS SULYTHEXOK T
P
FATOPIT
FU SE PTET
DANC BS.E   NADSTW  T COM
MANGMELEPRPRP  .EYT  TE EC
ROUBTH TPH
IOTIO SLE
THBL I TU.E >>
OME ARIOHI
EYHEORG TE, EREI TTHS ATUPCOAN I
HACOC,U IV TOMGE E D HAN HE, E P
'V C CSAVEWH
IMCUOVLETYROEN
S OUTI VID  ME THEREALON DIDNAE
RCE ME
ATNTY  AER